Một năm tham mời hàng thông tần truyết thức iro nở á của iroan đưa tin của họ nước này đã thông qua dữ lật sở bỏ
bốn số không quay công trên mạnh giá nông nổi tệ iroan.
Cuy định được lưu ra trong bối cảnh đồng nổi tệ của nước cộng hòa hôi giáo, mất giả mạnh trong thử dân qua.
Theo dữ lật với đo thông qua nông nổi tệ mới của iroan vẫn tiếp tục được gọi là iroan và đơn vị tiền tệ được gọi là iroan.
Sau khi thế đổi, một iroan mới sẽ măng mời iroan hiện tại và được chia thành một chăm diran.
Iroan sẽ cho phép cả tiền của vật tiền mới của mưu hành trong tối đà bà nâm và ngân hàng trù mất iroan có hai năm để thực hiện việc trên đối.
Zil lật phà ra đúng nổi tệ được thông qua tại của iroan với một chăm bốn mục phíao thuật,
một chăm lệ tảm phíao trộn và bảo phíao trắng.
Bởi vì có định trên iroan mông muốn đơn giảm hoa dấu dịch và giảm chí phi ít tiền.
Đông nổi tệ của iroan mất giả mạnh kể thực khi tổng thống tổng thống mi đường năng trông giúp mi khỏi thỏa thật thành nhân.
Măng tình kể hoa hành động trung tàn giận VCPOi được iroan khi vình ỏa phía năm cộng một năm 2020 và tảm át đập các lệ trường phạt lệ tí ran.
Ngoài ra các hạnh chế của cho ao trong đó có việc kích hoa dơ chế tảy át đập các lệ trường phạt của liên hấp quốc,
đồ vị iroan cũng là tắc nhìn gây nhiều khó khăn kìm tệ trọt tí hiểu ran.